we are back with a fox news alert and a
big one republicans are calling for new
york governor andrew cuomo to be removed
from
office after the new york post reports
one of his aides admitted to covering up
data on nursing home deaths
according to the associated press 15 000
nursing home patients have died from
covid
in new york state that is up from 8 500
previously reported
the secretary to the governor melissa
derosa made the comments about higher
totals during a video call with state
democrats
while trying to explain why the actual
numbers were withheld
fox news senior meteorologist janice
dean lost both of her in-laws to the
pandemic last year
she joins us now to react janice there
have been a few bombshells
hitting cuomo on this recently is this
the most damning
this is the most damning because someone
admitted it
and someone reported it and it looks
like
they covered it up the whole time and
the fact that they had a closed-door
meeting with democratic lawmakers
to apologize to them instead of the
people
who don't have their loved ones today is
just icing on the cake
how emotional was this when you heard
this news janice
yes emotional i didn't think i could be
more surprised than a couple of weeks
ago with the ag's report here in new
york
where she went ahead and investigated
the governor herself
into the nursing home numbers which we
all knew were under counted
uh we they were reporting over 6 000
for many months and now we're up to 15
000
another part of that bombshell is were
put into nursing homes
and they tried to dismiss that and say
that wasn't the cause of
all of the elderly that we lost in
nursing homes in the spring
so the fact that they have admitted this
and listen my hat's off to the leaker
the democratic lawmaker was in who was
in that meeting and decided to
bring it to the new york post who have
been doing heroic work by the way not a
lot of news media have been covering
this story which is why i'm so vocal
um yes today is a first step
into justice for my in-laws janice to
that point that you made
earlier what does it tell you about the
people involved
that their instinct in terms of an
apology
was to the democratic lawmakers who
could be potentially
hurt by this revelation when
there are people who will never see
family members
ever again yet they're worried about
some state senator
in elmira
look at this governor's track record his
leadership book his
emmy award protect only himself
and his administration and never we
never got an apology
or any remorse from this governor and
i believe he should be in jail i was
just gonna say what do you think should
happen
yeah i think a lot of people probably
feel that way
court of law full investigation the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
and jail time wow all right john steen
we're gonna be following it
thank you jen thank you